The last thing is but, but, how do we know
it's the right instruction? Remember we need to make our prediction
while we're fetching the instruction. So if this is a
return instruction, we need to use the return address stack, before
we even determine that it is a return instruction. We
cannot just keep pushing and popping things from the return address
stack, before we know it's a return. Because, for example,
if there is an ad and we pop from the return
address stack, then it's not going to work correctly. We actually need
to figure out, or at least very accurately predict, what's our
return instruction so that we can use the RATs appropriately. So
the problem is that we are using the RAT while fetching
the instruction. It's not been decoded yet, so we don't know
it's a return instruction yet. So how do we do it?
One way is to just use a very simple predictor that
will be trained on whether the instruction we're fetching is the
right or not. Simply, trying to predict or one
way or the other depending on whether it's a
rat or not and then make that predictor tell
us whether to use a [UNKNOWN] or not. This
would be a very likely accurate predictor. If, at
the particular PC, we have seen a RET instruction
previously then it is very likely that if we
see the same PC we still have a return instruction.
So we can use a single bit predictor
very easily here. Another approach, is to use
a so-called predecoding. We will soon see that
the processor really contains a cache that stores
instructions that have been fetched from memory. And
its fetching instructions from the cache, and only
if the cache doesn't already contain the instruction
it goes from memory. So the predecoding works by,
when I'm fetching from memory, I decode
enough of the instruction to know that it's
a return or not, and I store that
information along with the actual instruction in the
cache. So pretty much my memory will, for
example, have 32-bit instructions. In my cache I
will store 33 bits per instruction, 32 bits
of the actual instruction. And 1 bit that
tells me whether the instruction is a return or
not. So the idea is that as the instruction is
coming from memory, and we put it to cache.
We can pre-decoding instructions, keeping some additional bits in the
cache about the pre-decoding of the instruction. So that
when we fetch, we already know that information. The alternative
to this would have been to just fetch the
instructions from memory to cache as they are, and then
every time we fetch we have to figure out
what this instruction is. Because it's also more power-efficient
to do this once and then fetch instruction many
times rather than redo it every single time, pre-decoding
is a very popular approach. So pre-decoding is used
for things like, Is it a return instruction? Is
it a branch instruction at all? If we know
it's not a branch, than we can completely omit
the use of any branch vectors, thus saving a lot
of power. If our instructions are of variable sizes, predicoding
can also tell us, for example, how many bytes this
instruction is long so that we can fetch the next instruction
quickly and not. Rely on just the code in the
instruction before we can fetch the next one, and so
on. So there is a lot of things that modern
processors do in this pre-decoding phase. In order to avoid doing
it when we are on the clock, after we have fetched the instruction.